let's go next to our caller from the
seven-one-seven area code who's calling
today from seven one seven hi my name is
Omar hey Omar what's going on
everything's opened up and when I go to
the gym like most people aren't wearing
masks and like all the coffee shops like
there ton of people just sitting there
working that is really like worried
about predators virus now I I share that
concern now let me ask you this Omar if
the gym you've identified as a place
that looks dangerous
why are you going to the gym that's a
good question I really love the gym and
it makes me feel a lot better yeah so I
try to go there sparingly when there's
not a lot of people right I don't know
like I go maybe like twice a week like
normally I would have gone five times a
week
right no listen I understand I'm saying
my um my gym just emailed that they're
opening on Monday and workouts will be
limited to 90 minutes as if that's a
problem for me right Omar I mean I'm not
spending 90 minutes there but um you
know you're gonna you have to wipe down
every machine between use you're not
allowed to hang out and talk to people
you have to have your temperature taken
on that you know when I read the list to
me as like oh yeah it's clearly way too
dangerous it's warm right now I'll just
work out outside or do YouTube workouts
or what that's the call I made but I'm
totally with you I would love to be able
to safely go to the gym yeah they're
like no one's wearing that yeah view I
think it'd be a lot safer if everyone
wore masks absolutely not absolutely
well listen um I guess all we can do is
hope that it improves I I did go to a
coffee shop last weekend and you know
it's an outdoor seating only sort of
thing there were no tables with within
10 feet of me I posted a picture of it
on my Instagram it that felt safe and I
think I'm just I'm going to only do
things that feel safe the way that
they're being done in my state and so
I'll do outdoor dining I went and got my
hair cut wore a mask the entire time but
I'm gonna pass on the gym I'm gonna pass
on indoor for now
okay all right my friend thank you so
much for the call great to hear from you